we begin with clear signs that america's
coveted recovery
is slipping away because of the delta
variant and those who still refuse
to get vaccinated the u.s recorded more
than 194
000 new cases in a single day friday the
most since late january
missouri is among the hardest hit states
especially in areas
with low vaccination rates
hospitalizations in the state have
jumped
168 percent in the past two months and
behind
those numbers are many people regretting
their vaccine decisions
maria villarreal is in osage beach
missouri maria good morning
good morning anthony lake of the ozarks
is a popular tourist
destination it is a hot spot it brings
in more than 5 million people a year but
it has also become a covid hot spot and
even now as vaccines are becoming
politicized i spoke with a lot of health
care workers recently
and they are saying right now the
biggest challenge they are facing
is a lot of misinformation i love you
i love you billy baker and her son brody
have spent
17 days outside this missouri icu
where brody's father daryl is battling
covid
and is unable to have visitors the 31
year old was originally given
a 20 chance of survival and 10 of his
relatives tested positive for the virus
i was strongly against getting the back
seat just because
we're a strong conservative family but
that little boy out there arranged to
have a bag just over 40 percent of
missourians are fully vaccinated
the state's daily death rate more than
tripled in the past two weeks
at lake regional health system chief
medical officer
dr harbach senga says they're fighting
their fourth surge
the icu is busier than it ever has been
40 percent of
our inpatient senses is cobit what does
that do to your staff
we're struggling it's demoralizing
basically
to see that level of sickness and those
many deaths
last week they tied their highest number
of covet patients
since november of 2020 roughly half of
july's patients were under the age of 59
nearly all unvaccinated around town
crowded venues are welcoming guests
in droves the area attracted scrutiny
during the
early surges of the pandemic for drawing
large crowds of visitors
with few masks in sight and now
a year later many here resist getting
vaccinated
wouldn't wish this on anyone outside the
hospital
natalie who didn't want to share her
last name
camps under a tent for more than eight
hours a day
on one side of the window are messages
of love and support
on the other side is her 71 year old
mother
on a ventilator you just feel guilt over
what
that you didn't do more didn't know more
i respect people's wishes about the
vaccine and about
wearing masks i just ask you to give
grace to people who disagree with you
when i asked natalie if she had gotten
the vaccine immediately she shut down
she wouldn't tell us if her mother had
been vaccinated either that is how
polarizing that question has become
in this part of the country not far from
here in saint louis one of the biggest
health systems right now
is also reporting a record number of
cases and also
a record number of deaths gail maria
thank you it's a hot potato question no
matter where you are in the country
thank you very much